in 2016 a fierce indigenous LED movement
emerged at Standing Rock the world
watched called powerful oil cruelty and
police teamed up to unleash violence on
protesters ultimately the pipeline
company won now energy transfer Partners
is extending that pipeline to Louisiana
and another resistance is brewing this
time it's out in the swamps of Cajun
country across indigenous lands and
waterways and in communities of color
waging war on big oil isn't easy but
people here are not going down without a
fight
salt and gas is king in the media we are
gonna fight every inch of this pipeline
going to the ground in whatever way we
can
they're profiting off of our pain my
fighters clean water clean
[Music]
activists here called the pipeline the
blacksmith we call it you know taking
the snake and we're driving across the
Louisiana to talk to people affected and
see what they're doing to resist our
first stop Indian value this is the land
of refugees and survivors and drivers
I'm with Sharif Wheatland who runs the
LOI Lobby protest camp which means water
is life they travel to different
locations to disrupt pipeline
construction
we're resisting one of the largest like
Goliath type beasts in the world which
is the oil and gas industry it didn't
start at Standing Rock that people are
fighting especially indigenous people
there's just mothers grandmothers have
been fighting for ourselves and for this
land and for the water and the safety of
the people who live here for generations
upon generations upon generations energy
transfer Partners has spilled every 11
days on average for the past 15 years
the camp bought an 11 acre piece of land
in the pipeline's path which serves as
its headquarters the pipeline company
was forced to change its plans and
reroute around the camp because of the
hold out protesters have had run-ins
with police and pipeline security the
intimidation has been pretty pretty
intense at times there is some sort of
shadowy group that's around it's in very
dark tinted cars
I've been piggly-wiggly and then we take
a pictures of me and my kids you know
shopping for food or they'll be outside
my house or whatever they'll stop us and
for a traffic ticket with their guns
drawn it's almost like they want to see
something happen just being at camp is
pretty difficult it's 98 degrees right
now and oppressively humid so mosquitos
you got to worry about cuz they will eat
you up
since colonization happened indigenous
peoples here in Louisiana what's now
called Louisiana was a were pushed back
further and further into the swamps and
not only did they find a way to thrive
there
they also found a way to resist there is
gorgeous place worth protecting and
there's so much more to protect it I
worry about the idea that you know it's
all gone that it's all refineries and
chemical plants yeah our next stop is
out in Cajun country where a huge point
of contention is the pipeline running
through the Atchafalaya Basin the
biggest wetlands area in the United
States many Cajun people like Jody mesh
depend on it to make a living he's suing
the Army Corps of Engineers for allowing
ETP to come into the basin given the
damage past pipelines have done these
people make billions and billions of
dollars and there's no reason why you
should destroy such a sensitive
ecosystem and a sensitive world every
living you know what I'm telling y'all
when I get a trap full of dead crawfish
that ain't no good it's an indication of
like the canary in the mine shaft
Jody has been fishing here all his life
it was a trade that was passed down by
his father and his grandfather before
that I want to call about you notice
there's too much at stake
you know there's people's livelihoods at
stake there's numerous species of fish
and birds and I mean all types of marine
animals that survive out here the Cajun
people in the Cajun way of life we were
born and we followed our parents and
watch them do their living by fishing
and making their way of life in their
Calphalon Basin you know catching fish
crawfish punting stuff to eat and you
adapt to that real life you know you're
born into that a judge put a temporary
halt on pipeline construction due to
Jody's case the ruling was appealed and
now construction is back on right away
for the bayou for each bite you know I'm
worried about the risk of a 20 inch oil
pipeline potentially obstructing should
that all leak to a capacity that it
spreads across these thousands of acres
of critical habitat I mean oil companies
have changed the Atchafalaya Basin
already they clear large areas of trees
and bore down into the swamp bottom the
excess dirt dams up certain areas and
creates pockets of dead swamp where
nothing can survive
there's creatures that are relying on
this water it should have been better
taken care of than what it was and I
want to make sure that it's done better
in the future so we don't continue to
lose areas like what we've lost and none
of those creatures you know can give
interviews or arkin can go to
legislatures and cry out to you know the
people who are supposed to be doing the
job to represent the environment and
represent the people and represent them
another issue which is all too real in
Louisiana flooding dredging has caused
sediment buildup and the basin now has
less capacity to hold floodwaters the
water as it comes into the basin it has
to go higher up when the levee systems
putting our levee systems which which
are not up to par at greater risk of
breaching or topping and flooding
millions of people in countless
communities we're not opposed at all in
gas industry we're not opposed to your
jobs and what you know your job being
related at all in gas industry we just
know the job can be done better 75 miles
east there's another waterway that could
be seriously damaged
we're meeting with Monique Bearden a
tribal councilman for the homo nation
this water body behind me the Bayou at
fouché provides over 300,000 people
south of here with their drinking water
their bathing Potter there everything
water this really is the life line for
the United homo nation
you know the Houma dodged the Trail of
Tears by going deep into the Delta to
the ends of the bayous where they had
everything they needed because they were
able to provide for themselves if the
pipeline were to burst or if there was
to be an accident that's not only the
water for the Bayou Lafourche that's the
water for everybody in New Orleans
that's the water for everybody south of
New Orleans
Monique is part of a coalition of
indigenous women who focus on divestment
so they urge big banks to stop funding
companies that build pipelines on sacred
land when you look at this legacy of
colonialism here and then you follow the
pipeline money it leads back to Europe
to these big banks that are investing in
these corporations at the endpoint of
the pipeline our final stop is
where residents are pushing back Kerry
Joseph who postures a tiny Baptist
Church is like Joey suing the pipeline
company they buy beer pipeline you saw I
did twisted reality turn until it got to
Saint Jane do a lot of black never do a
lot of Hispanic there a lot of anymore
they went to melon Zweifel here for
years oil and gas companies have run
rampant on this low-income black
community people live with huge fuel
tanks in their backyards refineries and
pipelines are everywhere they need to
move up the road somewhere and let
people get to where they're all gonna
dangle get here I'll make sure that we
got enough tanks in there we got 118
tanks that's enough
but with the buyer your pipeline that
mean more things that means more are all
gonna be stories here that mean more
leaks gonna be that mean that more
smells gonna be here you know we got our
leak at 9:00 and nobody want to take the
responsibility st. James is in the heart
of cancer alley a stretch of Louisiana
with some of the highest rates of cancer
in the country inventive if you stayed
you're gonna die my church is a family I
don't look at my member that my remember
the other gang has my family because we
are very close and one of my members is
sickly she got cancer so that's why I'm
involved because when my people right I
heard when my people suffer previous
pipeline companies have closed off a
road that served as an evacuation route
for part of the community
people worry if there was leak or
explosion they would have no way out
it's not a one this is a need we need
evacuation run I'm gonna fight I'm gonna
do whatever I got to do but I don't
think we can overcome because once you
let one in and you let another one here
and you let another one in and you let a
body Britpop line here
you didn't let too much come in all
right Louisiana already has over 50,000
miles of pipelines and they're second
only to Texas and refineries while the
industry props up their economy they
also have the most to lose to the
effects of climate change which is
caused by these fossil fuel industries
we there's a football field of land
every 45 minutes in south Louisiana and
any land that goes into water becomes
property of the state and the state
leases it back to the oil and gas
industry one-third of the nation's oil
and gas is either being produced or
transported via South Louisiana but I
always like to remind people that we're
the best worst example when it comes to
poverty in America we're at the top of
the list when it comes to quality
education and health care we're at the
bottom of the list Louisiana has powered
all of the United States to great
sacrifice of ourselves you know we we at
this point are like a stage 4 lung
cancer patient that's continuing to
smoke you know it's time to make that
change so that we are actually able to
survive
[Music]